قدم لو جين
ووالداي شكاوى عدة مرات إلى
المدعي العام بشأن التعذيب إلى هيئة
حقوق الإنسان السعودية ، ولم
يرد علينا أحد منهم ونحن
ننتظر طويلاً ولم نحصل على
إجابة عن ذلك.
في الواقع ، مثلما توصل المدعي العام فعليًا
إلى استنتاج مفاده أن التعذيب
لم يحدث ، إنه ينفي التعذيب
، أشعر بالحزن لأن لا أحد يستجيب
لنا ، لم يتلق والداي أي رد في
المملكة العربية السعودية ، فهم في المملكة العربية
السعودية يتابعون القضية.
من خلال القنوات الرسمية
ولا نحصل على أي شيء أشعر
بالحزن لأننا نصرخ من أجل رؤية 2030
والشفافية التي
سنحظى بها ولكننا غير قادرين على حل
القضية من خلال
القنوات الرسمية التي نذهب إليها  من خلال وسائل
الإعلام لحل هذه المشكلة وأشعر بالحزن
فعليًا لوجودي في هذا العرض لمحاولة
إيجاد حل لا ينبغي أن أكون
في عرض لحل هذه الحالة ، يجب أن
يمر عبر القنوات الرسمية ولكن هذا
الشيء الذي لم يردوا به أبدًا على
قولنا ، هناك نقص في الشفافية ، لذلك
سمعت أن ولي العهد يقترح
أنه سيتابع ما هي
رسالتك إلى محمد بن سلمان ، ثم
الليلة ، حسنًا ، سأتحدث
عما يحدث بالفعل هناك.  في
الواقع في الواقع ، لم نحصل أبدًا على
إجابة عن ذلك ، وفي الواقع عندما توصلوا
إلى استنتاج مفاده أن التعذيب
لم يحدث ، لم يفعلوا أبدًا أنهم لم
يشرعوا في أي نوع من التحقيق الآن ،
دعونا نذكر أنفسنا بما
قاله المؤتمر بعد عام واحد فقط.  قبل ذلك ، قال في
مقابلته مع بلومبرج إن
لو جين ونساء أخريات كن جزءًا من
مؤامرة وأنهن يعملن
لصالح المخابرات الأجنبية ويحصلن على
أموال لتمويل الأشخاص الذين يعملون
في الولاية
لتقويض أمن الدولة الآن
لن أذهب.  للتعليق على هذا ، سأترك
الأمر للجمهور ليصدر حكمهم بأنفسهم ،
لكن رئيس الأطفال لا
يقول شيئًا عن ذلك أعتقد أن
لدى CNN نسخة من ذلك وهم ويذهبون
للوصول إليها ، قرأوا الرئيسة لا شيء
يقول إنها كانت تعمل لصالح
إيران وقطر ولم يذكر أي من ذلك
في الواقع ، كل التهم التي
تواجهها معظمهم تتعلق
بنشاطها في مجال حقوق الإنسان ولا شيء
يقول إنها  كان بمثابة تقويض لأمن الدولة من
خلال العمل مع المخابرات الأجنبية